Before we begin working with an animation within Unreal, we need to understand some
UE skeleton principles. So every skeleton needs to have one root bone. In gaming engines,
this is used to communicate to the engine where your character is within world space.
Off from that root bone, you're going to expand from your hip bone out to arms,
to legs, to head, whatever. But it's very important that this follows the same convention
in every skeleton you build. Now floating bones, they are seen as new skeletons. So if you have a
pistol with an armature and you have your skeleton for your character, they cannot be separated.
Otherwise, it will be seen as a separate element. This goes along with face bones. So if you're
having your face with multiple bones that controls the mesh, you want to make sure
that's attached to the head bone so that Unreal sees it all as the same when bringing it in.
So as this says, you want to start at the hip bone and work your way out from the root.
Thighs and spine from hip, spine into clavicles and neck, and so forth. And again,
face bones attached to the head bone. This is very, very important. Otherwise,
Unreal will see them as a separate skeleton and you'll have a mess to clean up.